>>> WHEN, LAURA HARRIS AND OTHE
FIGURES IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ENCOURAGED A MOB IN KENOSHA,
WISCONSIN AND THE SUMMER OF 2020
, KYLE RITTENHOUSE DECIDED
TO TRY TO DEFEND THE CITY.
A CAR LOT.
THE POLICE WERE NOT THERE.
HE WORKED IN KENOSHA.
HIS FAMILY'S FATHER LIVED THERE.
HE SHOWS UP AND TRIES TO GET
MURDERED.
KYLE RITTENHOUSE DEFENDS HIMSELF
.
OTHER PEOPLE TRIED TO KILL HIM
WITH A GUN.
FOR DOING THAT, HE IS PUT ON
TRIAL AND CHARGED WITH MURDER.
HE WAS ACQUITTED.
AT THE SAME TIME VIRTUALLY EVER
NEWS ORGANIZATION IN THE COUNTR
DEFAMED HIM AND CALLED HIM A
MURDERER BEFORE THE TRIAL ENDED
AND CALLED HIM REPEATEDLY A
WHITE SUPREMACIST, WHICH HE IS
NOT.
TECH PLATFORMS ENABLED THAT
DEFAMATION.
NOW KYLE RITTENHOUSE IS TAKING
LEGAL ACTION AGAINST THEM.
KYLE RITTENHOUSE IS THE FOUNDER
OF THE MEDIA ACCOUNTABILITY
PROJECT.
HE JOINS US NOW TO EXPLAIN WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
THANKS TO YOU FOR COMING ON.
TELIS, KYLE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WHAT ACTION ARE YOU TAKING
AGAINST THE TECH COMPANIES THAT
MADE THIS DEFAMATION POSSIBLE?
>> WE ARE GOING TO MAKE THE
MEDIA PAY FOR WHAT THEY DID TO
ME.
THEY MADE IT HARD FOR ME TO LIV
A NORMAL LIFE.
I CANNOT GO OUT IN PUBLIC.
I CANNOT GO TO THE STORE.
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO GO ANYWHERE
WITHOUT SECURITY.
DOING BASIC THINGS LIKE TAKING
DOG TO THE DOG PARK IS DIFFICULT
.
THEY MADE IT REALLY DIFFICULT T
BE NORMAL.
THEY AFFECTED FUTURE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES TO ME.
I DON'T THINK I WILL EVER BE
ABLE TO WORK OR GET A JOB
BECAUSE I AM AFRAID EMPLOYERS
MAY NOT HIRE ME.
TO ME I THINK IS ENTIRELY FAIR
BECAUSE OF THE LIES REPEATED FO
OVER A YEAR BY THE TECH
PLATFORMS THAT ARE NOT
JOURNALISTS.
THEY ARE SOLDIERS IN SOME SORT
OF WEIRD PARTISAN WAR THEY ARE
FIGHTING.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO RECTIFY
THIS?
>> WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING
THEM TO COURT.
GO AHEAD.
>> TELIS THE LEGAL ACTION.
>> SURE.
TO ANSWER YOUR FIRST QUESTION
WITH REGARD WITH WHAT WE PLAN T
DO, WE ARE LOOKING AT THOSE.
THE FIRST ONE I AM LOOKING AT I
FACEBOOK.
MARK ZUCKERBERG ANNOUNCED IN A
VIDEO WHAT KYLE WAS INVOLVED IN
WAS A MASS MURDERER AND THAT IS
CLEARLY DEFAMATORY AS WELL.
THAT IS NOT PROTECTED BY SECTIO
230 IN THE DECENCY ACT.
IN MY OPINION SECTION 230 ALLOW
YOU TO TAKE DOWN VIOLENT THINGS
OR THINGS THAT PEOPLE DON'T WAN
TO HEAR BY TELLING THE TRUTH
ABOUT KYLE WHICH IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT SECTION 230
ENABLED FACEBOOK TO TAKE DOWN.
THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE
PLAN TO DO WITH TECH AND PLAN T
DO IN THE DEFAMATION ARENA.
2 BY DEFAMATION ARENA, YOU MEAN
SO-CALLED NEWS ORGANIZATIONS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU MENTIONED SOME OF THAT ON
THE WAY IN.
CERTAINLY KYLE WAS CHARGED WITH
A CRIME.
NEWS ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALLOWED
TO REPORT ON THAT.
BUT CALLING SOMEONE A MURDERER
IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES CAN BE
ACTIONABLE.
OTHER THINGS THAT MEDIA
PERSONALITY AND PEOPLE ON SOCIA
MEDIA SAID WERE CLEARLY
DEFAMATORY.
I THINK YOUR COMMENT ABOUT
CALLING KYLE A WHITE SUPREMACIS
IS MADE UP OUT OF THIN AIR.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THE MEDIA CAN
CLAIM THEY DIDN'T MAKE A
STATEMENT MADE UP OUT OF THIN
AIR WITHOUT ENGAGING IN ACTUAL
MALICE OR MOST CERTAINLY
NEGLIGENCE.
I THINK WE HAVE SOME STRONG
GROUNDS TO PROCEED.
WE ARE LOOKING AT AN STARTING T
LOOK AT THOSE AND EVALUATE THEM
AND LOOK AT OPPORTUNITIES TO
HOLD THE MEDIA AND TECH
ACCOUNTABLE AS PROMISED.
>> KYLE, WHEN YOU GO INTO PUBLIC
, DO PEOPLE REPEAT TO YOU
THINGS THEY SAW ON SOCIAL MEDIA
OR ON NBC NEWS OR CNN?
>> THERE'S BEEN A FEW PEOPLE.
I RECEIVED SOME HARASSMENT.
THANK GOODNESS FOR MY SECURITY
FOR HELPING ME NOT HAVE TO GET
HARASSED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
KEEP ME SAFE AND IF SOMEBODY
DOES COME UP TO ME THEY MAKE
SURE THEY WILL NOT HARM ME.
THANK GOD FOR THEM.
>> TODD, REALLY QUICK.
HOW EXACTLY WILL YOU GO AFTER
MARK ZUCKERBERG?
>> I THINK WE WILL SUE FOR THE
DEFAMATORY STATEMENTS THAT KYLE
ENGAGED IN MASS MURDER AND FOR
VIOLATIONS OF SECTION 230 BY
TAKING DOWN POSTS THAT TOLD THE
TRUTH ABOUT KYLE.
IN ESSENCE THEY SUPPRESSED THE
TRUTH BY TAKING DOWN TRUTHFUL
POSTS AND THEY DID THAT IN
VIOLATION OF SECTION 230.
THAT DOES NOT PROVIDE PROTECTION
.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT'S NOT THAT THEY JUST DEFAMED
HIM BUT THEY ALSO TOOK DOWN ANY
DEFENSIVE HIM OR THE FACTS ABOU
HIM DEALING WITH THE VACCINES
AND OTHER THINGS THAT WERE IN
UKRAINE.
I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU ALL ARE
DOING.